ganz schön neugierig die kleine lea
kugelschreiber notizblock und auch die
kamera unseres fotografen wird ganz
genau unter die lupe genommen in der
menschenwelt scheint sich das
berberaffen baby absolute wohl zu fühlen
im tierpark töten würde ja gerade per
hand aufgezogen vor vier wochen kam sie
zur welt am ersten tag kümmerte sich
ihre mutter noch gut um sie am zweiten
tag stellte sich dann bei der gene so
ein paar komplikationen ein
sie wirkt leicht matt und kümmerte sich
nicht mehr so gut um das jungtier die
mutter wird krank und hat keine milch
mehr
tierparkchef david schaller engelmann
und seine mitarbeiter müssen das tier
mit der flasche aufziehen
inzwischen ist die mutter wieder gesund
doch aufgrund der distanz konnte sich
keine funktionierende
mutter-kind-beziehung zulia entwickeln
inzwischen hat die kleine eine enge
bindung zu ihren menschlichen pflegern
aufgebaut
sie sind uns sehr ähnlich vom verhalten
her aber wir können halt nicht die
kompletten verhaltensweisen ersetzen und
möchten schon dass wir relativ schnell
in die gruppe kommt einfach dass sie ja
auch weiß dass die iaaf ist in zwei
monaten wird lia zuerst stundenweise zu
den anderen affen ins gehege gelassen
bis sie dann irgendwann komplett bei
ihrer richtigen familie einzieht